(audience cheering)
- Well, meet Iman, meet Howie.
- Hi.
- Pleased to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- It's very colorful.
- Like this is what happens
when you wash your black pants
with her dress.
- Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
- I know, we're coordinated today.
- I love it. I love this
dress. It's so cute.
- Thank you. Thanks!
- How are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
I've been so excited to come on this show.
- Oh my gosh, me too.
- And congrats on all
the Emmy nominations,
like-
- Thank you!
(audience applauds)
- Yeah. Thank you.
- What are you bad at? I don't know.
- Oh, many things.
Yep. Just ask my therapist.
So we need to get into
something very important though.
So a few weeks back you
tweeted, years back, not weeks.
Years back, she tweeted this,
"Guys, I hate to tell you
this, but red wine is gross."
(gasps) And I came back to
you online and was like,
"#Blasphemy, I mean, maybe you
haven't had the right glass
of Pinot Noir is all I'm saying."
Have you changed your mind?
Do you like wine at all now?
- I like it. I'm trying to-
- Yeah.
- like get cooler with
reds, but I'm just like-
- Okay. It can be a real-
- a white girl.
- No. Okay, well, I'd
like to change your mind.
So I just, Justin? Here he's coming, okay.
- [Howie] Oh wow.
- [Maren] Oh, my goodness.
- [Kelly] I wanna have a chance.
- Justin!
- I wanna have a chance.
(audience applauding)
Look at this, check this out.
Now what are we, I'm
very excited about this.
What are we letting her taste?
- We are having a 2019
Kosta Browne Pinot Noir
from Duckhorn.
It has enticing aromas of-
- Ooh.
- fresh blueberry, blackberry-
- and lilacs,
that envelope the senses.
A layered acidity and
a long powerful finish.
- Ooh.
- Wow.
- I like the words, I...
- Okay.
- In one ear out the other.
- Doesn't he sound like
he knows what he's talking about?
- Okay. Yeah.
- Okay.
- Just like-
- He sounds like
he knows what he's reading.
- Will it get me drunk?
- Yes!
- Okay. That's all I really care about.
- I mean, people have told me-
- Can I have the peanuts?
- "Just shake it around."
Can I have the peanuts?
- Okay.
- Can I have the-
- Oh my God, for a minute I was like,
"Wait, what?" (laughs)
(Maren laughing)
(audience laughing)
- I was like, "Sir?"
- Peanuts Noir.
- Thank you.
- I'm sorry. (laughing)
- Okay, wait. Taste
it. Just see, I'm just-
- You sniff it, right?
- Make sure you sniff it
first, like, smell it as you-
- Like, what do I do?
- It's opened. It's opened,
we've opened it for you.
- [Howie] Wow.
- Mmm.
- You're lying. Are you lying? (laughs)
- Okay. This is the only kind of red wine
I can drink is like, Pinot Noirs. because-
- Okay.
- they're not gritty, and-
- [Kelly] Yeah! That's why I like 'em.
- and yeah, I mean they'll-
- They're not too earthy-
- make your teeth purple, but-
- they do make your...
- And there's a hint.
Isn't there a hint of, what is it?
- [Kelly] Blueberry?
- Right.
- Blueberry?
- Lilac.
- And some Lilac.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- I love those like,
sommelier explanations-
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- when they, especially red wine,
they get so all about themselves.
- With the hint of...
- They're like "Mmm, tennis
balls. It's tennis balls."
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
- Okay. Justin, thank you so much.
- You're very welcome.
- Thank you, Justin!
- [Howie] Thank you, Justin.
(audience applauding)
- Okay. So one thing that we
definitely agree on is music.
I love your music.
We were talking about your
music earlier and it's so good.
And it's so diverse, you're country,
but you also have these
hints of like R&B and pop
and like singer-songwriter.
- Hint.
- It's very-
- With a hint of, you say it.
- With a hint of blueberry and lilac
- Blues-berry.
(Howie chuckles)
- Blues-berry. No, but it's really cool.
So I even love her so much,
I asked to record one of her
songs called "Second Wind".
It's a really a cool song.
Your new album's called "Humble Quest".
- What does it say on your back?
I've been reading your back.
- What's your back?
- I know,
I've been trying to like...
- Wait, what's your back say?
- It's a Patty Griffin quote.
(Kelly gasps)
- And I love Patty.
- I love Patty!
- I know you...
Okay. So your cover of "Top of the World"?
- I love Patty.
- Or no, "Up to the Mountain".
- Oh, if you-
- "Up to the Mountain"!
- love Patty, you would love
her back. She likes backs.
- [Kelly] Wait, which
one is it? Which one?
- It's from her song, "Christina".
- Wow.
- And it was like my second tattoo ever.
I think I was like 19,
and it says, "It's a wondrous
world of ridiculous things-
(Kelly gasps)
- but nothing so rare as
the love that it brings."
And I, haven't-
- Aw.
- I have "The Cat in the
Hat" on my inner thigh.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God.
(audience laughing)
- I got like really into
stick-and-pokes lately. And-
- I don't have-
- I've just been like
giving myself tattoos.
- What?
- It's terrible, yeah.
- I don't have the stomach
for the stick-and-poke.
- It gets numb after two rounds, you know?
- Oh my god, wait, what?
- I'm learning so much about you.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- And I'm like floored.
- Yeah. I don't like,
even when I get tattoo-
- You have no interest in me?
- Well-
(Kelly and Maren laughing)
- The man eating-
- He doesn't like-
- peanuts in the back.
- to spoon.
- Well now I'm just like,
"Stop talking about my music,
I need to know more about-
- What you're listening to.
- the stick-and-pokes."
- Yeah.
- Hey, I brought my kit.
We can hang out and-
- "My kit"? (laughs) You have a kit?
- Let's do like a KC, like your initials-
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Like to commemorate us doing
this show for the first time.
- Look at that.
- Oh my gosh, I'm not-
- Making friends.
- I'm in.
- Love it.
- Yeah, right!
- On your head though.
- Yeah, right.
- Gonna get a prison tattoo.
- On your head.
- A big BS right now.
- Yeah.
- I would.
- Big BS. Wait, I wanna
talk about "Humble Quest".
Why'd you name it that?
- I named it "Humble Quest",
'cause I had my son at
the beginning of COVID,
like as everything shut down
and it's my first kid, really.
And so it was so much uncertainty of like,
I'm bringing a baby into
the most chaotic time
of human history right now,
or least of our lifetimes.
And then also all my
touring got canceled, and-
- Oh yeah.
- you know,
for the last two years.
So it was just, I don't know,
like humbling for the worlds
to go through these last few.
And for me as someone that's like, I mean,
I hate to say this, in a
very self-indulgent industry,
everything being shut down
gave me a lot of perspective,
and I didn't feel like I
took it for granted before,
because that seems kind of hyperbolic
but I definitely appreciate
it even more now.
- Yeah.
- Being able to like-
- I think a lot of us-
- make music for a living.
- us appreciate things like, yeah.
- Yeah. So-
- And you didn't get to tour,
like people are just now touring again.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And so it just felt kind of apropos
to name it "Humble Quest",
because it's like it's an ongoing journey.
It's not gonna end, like the
second I go back on stage.
It's gonna be evergreen. So-
- Yeah.
- yeah. that's kind of...
- What's your, like I know
they're all our babies,
like on our albums,
but what's like your one that
you're in love with right now.
Which song?
- Oh my god, okay. The song "Hummingbird",
I wrote the day I found
out I was pregnant.
- Aw.
- And then,
I had my son at the beginning of 2020,
and then it was just
about, like, the line is-
- [Howie] Oh, he's adorable.
- Aw.
- Oh god, yeah. That's him.
- Wow.
- The back of him.
(Kelly laughing)
- But the line in the chorus is like,
"Hummingbird, now your
heart beats in me." And-
- Aw.
- by the time
I was recording the song
with my producer Greg,
my son was starting to talk.
And so at the top of that
song, you hear a little
like voice memo recording
of him just saying "Mama".
And so-
- Aw.
- I mean-
- Oh I love that.
- it's hard to pick one, but
like that one, I think I'm,
I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to get through live,
but yeah.
- I hate when I do that.
- He's cute.
- When you write
something that you need to
get out and you wanna get out and share
but then you're like,
"Oh, I get to do this
for the rest of my life."
- Yeah.
- Yeah. And it's like-
- I know. It's real.
- tense.
Well Maren's new album
is called "Humble Quest".
Go get it everybody.
(audience applauding)
and tickets to her US
tour are on sale now!